unter [ __ ] you less than diesel und
joker und tilly und jugend influencers
riact bundestagswahl steht vor der tür
die heute show hat mich gebeten den
digitalen wahlkampf der parteien zu
kommentieren losgeht mann
[Musik]
man sieht so aus als ob der denn bei gar
nicht selbst kick weil es kommt null
quinns über es kommt so rüber als könnte
er das sogar ich es trotzdem kurios er
sein lieber gartenzwerg einfach jeder
mensch ist frei und es gibt ja noch
andere möglichkeiten um gesund zu
bleiben zb die sauna kommt mit mir mit
ich lade euch recht herzlich ein
was kommt mit mir mit ich lade euch
recht herzlich ein
ich lade euch recht herzlich ein ich
lade euch recht herzlich ein
wer will mit dem robin in die sauna
gehen
mach mal einer auf dem fast nochmal
sondern den bademantel könnte auch bei
meiner eltern kamen gegen st
aber ich mag die sonne halten nicht
alles ja hallo liebe seine videos mehr
die wisst ihr vorstellig kamera an
gemacht ist raus aus dem bild in sich
drin zu setzen
sportschützen gottes willen
ja hallo also war er gerade am job oder
warum warum ist er so aus der puste
wir freuen uns dass es ja noch
langweiliger als das davor sitze gerade
im keller
wer das geführt dass er so ein bunker
ist so ein krieg in was für ein keller
hat ja das gedreht was ist das denn
was wir wollen sorry aber könnte ich mir
leider nicht meint sein kollege wir sind
in der letzten pause bei unserem
hybriden die ersten 30 listenplätze
schon gesehen kommen jetzt noch das
nächste konfessionell und ich wusste gar
nicht dass man auf instagram so ne
formate buch blickt also ein komisches
video und begeistert klingt ja auch
nicht und hat auch keiner kommentiert
sagen wir mal keine worte letzte sie hat
auch so gar kein interesse an dem was er
sagt
die körpersprache ist richtig so
besonders niedrig gar nicht nur das
musterfall anstrengend sein die ganze
zeit sein knie so einzuknicken
[Gelächter]
ich bin begeistert kann ich aber
nachvollziehen als das erste mal vor der
kamera stand war ich auch ehrlich gesagt
sehr sehr unsicher
aber da kommt man irgendwann rein warum
sollte cannabis nennen kritisiert werde
das verbot von cannabis ist krachend
gescheitert
deswegen foto kriminalisierung von
keiner wissen
ok los du bist nicht blöd das merkt man
hier und er hat sich richtig also hat
richtig kasse effekte gemacht sie dieses
handy so eingehalten hatten dann kam so
dieses video das war das war nicht
schlecht nutzt das war cool sehr stabil
sei stabil
ich weiß nicht wie viele tüten und dar 1
diesmal lieber aber ich bin dagegen
[Musik]
immer noch spd warum denn das friends
ihr habt nicht ernsthaft tappte googelt
und vom laptop einfach ach du meine güte
[Musik]
mai
ja auch sich am ende dann worunter ich
drin ich so gut versteht nichts von dem
was er sagt thon bei videos ist sehr
wichtig ja das kann ich mir da jetzt
nichts mehr findet man angucken
würden wir nichts verstehen man denkt
sich nun der arme mensch der weiß gar
nicht was hier gerade passiert
er versteht das alles gar nicht bitte
nehmt doch nicht euren opa der einfach
nur seine ruhe haben will und sagt die
man soll sich vor der kamera stellen und
so tun als würde er luftgitarre spielen
es ist wieder ein ganz gutes titel weil
man kann und es trifft ihn mehr und es
hat einfach 51.000 aufrufe okay
vielleicht versteht das doch eher ein
40.000 likes sogar leute das war's
jedoch mache jetzt nicht meinen kanal zu
abonnieren abonniert der abonniert den
kanal den kanal von heute von der
heute-show abonniert werden auch im
eigenen kanal
ob ich auf den banken schaffen